it is cold outside if you head out
without a jacket or a coat you are going
to be sorry oh my goodness you're going
to run inside and get it before you go
anywhere we are down to 30s with clear
skies and light winds this morning only
a couple of spots left in the 40s in
fact it's only downtown at well
Centennial Hills you're at 40 42
downtown everybody else in the very cold
30s this morning 29 at Red Rock 26 up at
Kyle Canyon few breezes up in the spring
mountains 29 now in prom 28 at Indian
Springs teens in Caliente in single
digits up in Ely 35 for Mesquite 38 for
Boulder City we've got 30s in
Searchlight 52 in Laughlin and below
freezing in Kingman running the wind
forecast today looks fine but once we
get into Friday we get more
northeasterly breezes returning and some
of those could even come back right into
our Saturday early in the morning and
through the afternoon now they're not
going to be as strong as what we had
earlier in the week and no wind
advisories have been issued but it's
still going to make it feel extra chilly
where it's really going to be cold the
Northern Plains winter weather
advisories issued and the Great Lakes
looking for a huge snowstorm over the
next several days the lake effect snows
will be piling up two three plus feet in
some areas high pressure delivering lots
of good sunshine today but there will be
some high level clouds just kind of
sneaking in under that Ridge of high
pressure by tonight and tomorrow coming
in from the West Coast so look for more
clouds tonight and a few still around
for our Friday 60 degrees today still
well below normal 66 now as the
afternoon High even cooler for the
weekend with upper 50's and then as we
get into next week a lot of people
traveling and going to see family and
friends I think it's going to warm up a
little bit mid to Upper 60's for
Wednesday into Thanksgiving Thursday